you have to know and love
attainments and fulfillments your
qualifications and Seavey's don't really
matter
instead life is difficult and
complicated and beyond anyone's control
the humility to know it will help you
survive its vicissitudes this is the
second big word that I'd like but I
don't want to sound dark my whole fall
of you is that you retain a lifelong
love of learning that you never cease to
dream exciting and inspiring dreams and
when you fail you don't and you fail you
fail well enough to succeed the next
time don't be afraid of being afraid be
afraid of not facing your fears and
failures as I was coming here and this
is my dream I was telling the press
outside when I walked in here I sent a
message to my little daughter who's 11
and a half my son 14 and I said it's one
of the most beautiful institutions I've
seen in my life genuinely you guys are
fortunate to be studying here and and
everything I really wish my kids are
good enough like you all you young boys
and girls and all the parents who've
helped them do this are good enough to
reach here and study and get this
opportunity so I wrote to my daughter
and said so pretty and nice and
beautiful I wish you could come and
study here and she sent me back a long
message as she always does is it pretty
papa
is it nice it is snowing there because I
told a last I always say it was snowing
and my son sent me one alphabet K
which I have understood when you extend
means okay yeah